[Applause]
Thank You mr. president of the European
Parliament estimates memory.i honourable
members of the European Parliament
ladies and gentlemen it's an honor and a
privilege for me to be here today in the
European Parliament I'd like to thank
you for this invitation to take part in
the debates around the future of the
European Union the Union has long been
marked but in particular over the last
decade by multiple challenges which have
tested cohesion and unity from the
financial and economic crisis the
migration crisis terrorist attacks to
the rising up of populist movements this
decade has been one in which the Union
has had to learn how to adapt on the
hoof against the backdrop of those
challenges the Union has been marked by
the search for a common vision defined
through the need to achieve a smart
balance between the specific realities
of every member state and the wish to
consolidate together a genuine union a
union that looks to the future the main
positive finding in this period is that
there is a factor that unites us a
European identity based on shared
principles values and interests and
these
values these common values must
constantly be rediscovered we
appreciated and given the Jew value back
again because the universalism of values
lies precisely in their ability to
regenerate and now we are coming into a
new chapter in the rise and
consolidation of the European project in
which we need to come up with a new
vision with regard to the future of the
Union in that perspective I would firmly
plead for unity for cohesion for
solidarity and for a common European
path in the course of our efforts to
consolidate that European project the
central key to our approach must remain
unity for Romania this principle
embodies the very essence of the
European project which gives it this
ability to cope with multiple challenges
as the Union has been contending with
hitherto the European Union is a project
that's on the move new realities both
member state level as globally require
the development and consolidation of the
European project and in no case should
it lead us to challenge the fundamental
principles on which the European project
has been built a powerful union should
not be achieved to the detriment of
unity we need an inclusive union which
leaves no member state or no citizen
behind
from that point of view the idea of a
multi-speed Europe or a union of
concentric circles cannot offer a
solution to the extent that we wish to
preserve its unitary and indivisible
character as a European Union and that
is what imbued it with value and
credibility in its relations with the
rest of the world president Janka last
year said that Europe needed to get its
breath back to breathe with both its
lungs that on the East and that on the
West
I do hope that our future together
will demonstrate to us similarly that
Europe has just one heart a heart that
beats in a song that unites us in the
east as in the West in the north as in
the south and which leads to our
citizens quite naturally identifying and
defining themselves as Europeans we must
take up this common ideal for ourselves
and if necessary to adapt ourselves and
to recalibrate the instruments which
will allow us to achieve this I am
confident that the new step on which the
European Union is embarking in 2019 and
in which Romania in its capacity as the
rotating presidency of the Council of
the European Union will prepare together
with the other member states and the
European institutions will be a fertile
future I'm confident that the Sibiu
summit to be held on the 9th of May 2019
will be a benchmark
in planning a future involving a more
powerful more United and low cohesive
and more democratic Union this hinges on
our strength on our intelligence and our
will as member states European
institutions and European citizens to
make that objective a reality ladies and
gentlemen the Sibiu summit is an
important stage in the consolidation of
the foundations of that future a common
future a democratic future and an
optimistic future the future of the
European Union cannot be built but
through the participation and direct
involvement an active involvement of the
citizens of Europe and I would like
severe to be a moment of dawning
awareness on the part of the citizens of
Europe citizens the citizens want to
gauge tangible palpable results they
want good news about peace security and
prosperity
similarly the citizens need to see that
we are working to protect and
consolidate the chief symbols of the
Union the euro currency the internal
market the Schengen space and freedom of
movement
at the same time our citizens need more
cohesion but cohesion is not simply the
ambition of the new member states alone
which are experiencing lower levels of
economic convergence but also it's a
necessity for the older members of the
union cohesion is unity it speaks of
common action action consort our
concerted and coordinated at the EU
level we must go back to the main
essence of the principle of cohesion as
is reflected in Treaty of the Union
namely is a converging power of a
community of vision and action which can
create added value for the Union as a
whole the European Union today finds its
state finds itself in a stage of
economic recovery this would not have
been possible in the absence of common
vision and action to create and
consolidate an economic and monetary
union economic security is just as
important as border security while the
prosperity of the Union depends on our
ability to ensure a powerful capable
economic and monetary union that can
meet the expectations of the citizens
but which can also cope with new
challenges with a view to achieving that
objective we need comprehensive
decisions and policies which guarantee
the involvement of all member states in
a common effort to create a more
powerful a more stable and a more
competitive euro zone
for Romania membership of the eurozone
as soon as possible when all the
conditions are met is a fundamental
national objective this year we are
celebrating 25 years of the internal
market we have come a long way as
regards with the freedom and opportunity
to travel to study and to work elsewhere
in the European Union for our citizens
we cannot imagine a European Union
without a single market and without its
four fundamental freedoms the free
movement of goods the free movement of
people the free movement of services and
the free movement of capital we need a
functioning competitive and inclusive
single market a single market in which
the citizens really feel its benefits in
their day to day lives at the same time
Europe is and must remain an
international leader in many fields
above all with regard to the
technological and digital revolution
Europe does have the capacity and the
strength to transform itself into and to
be a leader in connectivity growth and
stability competitiveness security and
the improvement of the quality of life
of all Europeans also depend on how
ambitious and how resolute Europe is as
regards digitalization including
research and innovation at the same time
we must ensure that we adapt our workers
better to the needs
requirements and changes in the single
market to guarantee social progress and
competitiveness go hand in hand we must
also be aware that the fact that society
is changing digitally cannot be realized
without huge investment in education and
in acquiring the necessary skills all
citizens from whatever region or
whatever social class must be engaged in
this revolution in this evolution that
must be our commitment the commitment of
Europe's leadership and in that
diversity our continent will be
strengthened in the global competition
which will follow we're talking of a
future in which the Union will win back
its own citizens by increasing their
feeling of being in security here at
home within the Union the challenges
which are brought about by migration and
security are paramount interest for us
all
we must act to ensure that the European
project can rebuild security for the
citizens and to devote more attention to
fighting terrorism and radicalization
we need to act we need to become more
proactive and we need to increase the
--use planning capabilities as a
response to the crisis using contextual
policies cannot be an efficient way of
working and we need lasting solutions
the European Union must remain an area
of free movement one in which our
citizens can move freely and can work
anywhere in the EU territory where young
people can travel can study and can thus
benefit fully from one of the most
visible and ambitious projects of
European integration namely the Schengen
zone for Romania membership of the
Schengen zone is an important objective
this step will appreciably contribute to
the consolidation of the security of an
entire area of free movement for the
Union as a whole the corollary of a safe
and powerful Union must be a bigger
Union because
with size will come power that notion is
all the truer and all the more relevant
in a global context which is highly
competitive and the union's enlargement
policy has clearly demonstrated the
value arising from successive waves of
new members which incontrovertibly have
contributed to the prosperity and
security of the continent enlarging the
Union should not remain a desire merely
for the generations to come it must
continue to be a real necessity in which
candidate countries and potential
candidate countries can anchor their
ongoing reform efforts and can take on
seriously and lastingly
the values and principles of Europe
honourable members of the European
Parliament we cannot really be relevant
globally
if we cannot significantly influence the
settings of our neighbourhood keeping
the countries in our southern eastern
neighborhood firmly anchored in the
values of Europe and maintaining our
commitment to irreversible structural
reform working together with them
depends on our ability to live up to the
pledges we've given them and last but
not least we're talking about a future
in which the European Union will have a
front of stage role on the international
stage a future in which the merriebeth
States
based on shared interests a mutual
solidarity will support the assertion of
the Union as a global player with a
decisive contribution towards promoting
a multilateral system which is based on
rules the implementation of the --use
global strategy has seen significant
changes both in security and defence as
in the consolidation of our political
ties both within the EU and outside the
EU it's our responsibility to ensure
that in the years to come
the European Union will have the
instruments it needs to meet new
challenges ongoing initiatives in
security and defence common security and
defence based on close cooperation and
the avoidance of parallel structures
with NATO the consolidation of the
union's resilience and that of its
partners and the improvement of our
strategic communication are all
objectives which require greater
attention and constant action the
consistency of the union's policies in
its neighborhood the preservation of a
solo transatlantic partnership in the
honoring of our commitment to
enlargement within agreed parameters and
to institutional relations with the UN
and the support for multilateralism are
all virtues and areas in which the Union
will find it needs to demonstrate that
it can act efficiently distinguished
members of the European Parliament
11 years ago when Romania joined the
greater European family
I felt especially proud as a Romanian to
be living through that important time
for my country next year when Romania
for the first time assumes the
presidency of the Council of the
European Union the Sibiu summit will be
a crossroads moment for our European
family it's our duty it's our
responsibility to create Europe's future
alongside every Romanian I feel proud to
be a citizen of Romania and in equal
measure a citizen of Europe because
national pride and European pride are
not worn-out concepts they are not
parallel realities it's a conscious
state which conserves and give strength
in content to those identities because
Europe is part and parcel of our very
fiber a Europe that comes together from
our diversity a Europe that is based on
the concept of unity in diversity and
thus Europe is Romania and Romania is
Europe 2018 is the centenary year of
modern Romania which for us all means
not so much a backward-looking analysis
of history but much more
plans for the future in those 100 years
we have learned some important lessons
and we have indeed gone through unhappy
times but the lesson of democracy is one
of the most important of those lessons
and that is why we appreciate all the
more the values of the European family
for that reason Romania is a country
which is deeply attached to the European
project we have a vibrant and dynamic
society and one that is constantly
changing we are young democracy which
has the wherewithal to improve Romanians
are actively linked to civic values
I think that's demonstrated as clearly
and calm as can be when there has been
the need to speak up for the rule of law
and democracy Romanians have the will
and the strength to go further down this
European road that they have embarked on
it's about the ambition to overcome any
obstacle to remain firmly embedded in
the greater European family to which we
fundamentally belong the young
generation believes in Europe and is
engaged in debates about our future in a
positive and above all optimistic way
and the enthusiasm of these remarkable
young people also feeds into our
optimism about Europe's future
nonetheless this enthusiasm they
put a particular obligation on us to be
responsible the advantage of this wave
of enthusiasm means that Europe is in
the front like frontline of thinking
about how to protect democracy democracy
is not just given to us
it requires ongoing responsibility to
care for it protect it and promote it
yeah Romania at present is a dynamic
country that looks to the future that
has rapidly embraced and worked on the
new technological trends in digital
services one of Romania's companies has
in recent years become a world leader in
cyber defence and security moreover her
company begun by two young engineers
this spring became Romania's first
unicorn in just six months the company
has tripled its value reaching an
evaluation of 3 billion euros becoming a
global leader in robotic software
automation and artificial intelligence
throughout Romania from - totally shuara
from Cluj to bucharest from cry over to
constants thousands of talented romanian
engineers both men and women are working
to advanced digital technologies whether
we're talking about connected cars or
intelligent transport systems or 5g
telecoms or the Internet of Things
they're researching and innovating in
blockchain spatial technology and
digital agriculture the data economy is
the future
and sectors of the Romanian economy
information technology and communication
technology and the creative sectors
becoming some of the most influential in
terms of our GDP nationally in that of
the Union as a whole it should therefore
not surprise anyone that Romania wishes
to and is also able to contribute to
consolidating the EU's global role in
this field Romania actively supports a
union that invests in the security of
its citizens European unity is vital
whenever we talk about consolidating the
union's internal security for Romania as
a member state that manages one of the
longest external borders of the EU
security is a priority area in which we
have demonstrated that we can perform in
every respect today we are capable of
supplying security at the very highest
standards for the Union as a whole as
indeed we are already doing within NATO
as a member state of the union we will
devote special importance to ongoing
measures aimed at reducing the
fragmentation of Europe's security space
it's our duty to protect all the
citizens irrespective of where they are
whether they're in Schengen member
states or not this is possible only
through continuing to take an integrated
approach to the external border of the
EU and all Member States need to do that
in respective
also using the latest generation of
security instruments distinguished
members the European Parliament the
European Union was built on a desire
which is as human as it is profound to
experience peace on the European
continent that internal peace with all
its component parts which is to say
cooperation between member states the
principle of the rule of law fundamental
rights and freedoms diversity prosperity
social standards and labor standards all
that has become an extremely valuable
export the time has come to go back to
that model which is part of our very
being and to show to our citizens that
we have managed to create that together
to see how we are together protecting
peace and how the need for peace today
is in the interest of all citizens I
always have in the back of my mind the
very topical words once spoken by jean
monet to quote in french there is no
future for the peoples of europe than
that of Union end of quote I urge us all
to maintain unity as a very watchword
for our future but that unity will not
come under its own steam
it's a unity that we have to protect and
to consolidate constantly caring for it
as we do at the same time for diversity
also Europe's cultural characteristic
thank you very much for your attention
[Applause]